quel bordel ici vous portez quelques
petits jours comme ça à londres et à san
francisco c'est le bazar lumière une
lumière deux ans mais en bleu voilà à
l'image de l'arrière ne sais pas
pourquoi je me retrouve avec des bottes
je me suis toujours posé la question
pourquoi est ce que ma famille lisez ça
est ce qu'elle peut faire passer un
message en le posant juste là je sais
pas comme ça vous voyez touria les
coulisses les installations les
désinstallation ça là on est pas mal bon
ça va comment ça va bien bien bien bien
bien
bon moi ça m'a pas trop mal cette
semaine était extrêmement changé san
francisco londres lâche tandonnet
dimanche pas de repos pour les guerriers
et je voulais vous parler d'un
smartphone dont j'ai eu l'occasion en
tout cas de vous parler cette semaine
c'est les nouveaux smartphones qui ont
été présentés en chine par li jun xiaomi
sont les chiens ont mis ni disent les
milices pro alors les milices et me
disent pro sont présentés un peu en
avant première en chine avant d'être
officialisé lancer vraiment façon
internationale fin février le lancement
devait avoir lieu le 23 février dans le
cadre du mwc quelques jours avant le mwc
malheureusement le mwc a été annulée
chez omi a annulé sa conférence tout est
annulé
c'est un bazar astronomiques et ils
seront présentés à une date ultérieure
et que je ne connais pas aujourd'hui il
m'aurait été dévoilé dix jours avant le
lancement officiel le 13 février 2020 ça
nous permet de voir effectivement déjà
ce que sont ces produits sur la fiche
technique alors effectivement pour s'en
rendre compte il faut les avoir en main
une connection je connais les produits
de chômage en est des quantités en main
je m'attends à ce que ces produits
soient vraiment de bonne qualité sur le
haut de gamme sur le plus haut de gamme
de ce que fait schumi me dise milices
pro alors la question à se poser
je connais les tarifs de sept produits c
est ce que schumi est toujours une gamme
low cost est ce que je suis on y est
toujours
une gamme qui vient pour écraser les
prix un peu comme un goutte à l'époque
qui écrasait les prix est ce que c'est
c'est un truc en tout cas paul school
est ce que c'est ça l'idée est ce que je
suis on me met toujours le challenger
celui qui vient faire mal aux autres
avec des fiches techniques de ouf à des
tarifs défiant toute concurrence on peut
se poser la question parce qu'on avait
très mal et haïti sont très haut on se
rapproche vraiment des tarifs du haut de
gamme chez apple et chez samsung
lorsque vous regardez déjà le côté
design l'aspect et c'était que du
produit on voit qu'on a un écran qui est
extrêmement grand avec des bords
incurvés sur le côté on a petit point
sont qui est en haut à gauche du
smartphone le point se retrouve là était
déplacé au sens cette fois ci chez
samsung sur ces nouveaux galaxy s
1 le poisson donc toujours d'actualité
schumi n'a pas fait le choix d'intégrer
une caméra popote pourtant ils l'ont mis
sur d'autres modèles milieu de gamme
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont fait ce
qu'ils pensaient de cette technologie
n'était pas suffisamment bonnes
suffisamment performante et suffisamment
intéressantes pour le diamètre sur l'or
flagship ça serait le problème en
question a alors posé on retrouve un
design qui fonctionne bien d'appareils
photos logé sur le côté à la verticale
bruballa ça marche rien qu'un dames le
produit est suffisamment intéressant et
alléchant bien évidemment il faudra le
tester le prendre en main j'avais donc à
vous abonner parce que ce sera bientôt
le cas comme ça vous saurez tout un
capteur d'empreintes digitales sous
l'écran bombe grands standards du côté
de chez shiomi que ce soit sur le midi
soul milices pro on se retrouvera le cas
d'écrans de 6,7 pouces c'est de la
molette c'est une dalle samsung ratio
19,5 9ème compatible hd hier 10 plus et
nous annonce une luminosité allant
jusqu'à 1200 dit donc très très très
lumineux il ya un truc qui me chagrine
un petit peuple qui est fondamentalement
bien mais qui me fait penser à un
smartphone un petit peu 2019 c'est le
taux de rafraîchissement choc mais nous
annonce un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 hertz au niveau de son écran alors
qu'est ce que ça apporte sa porte plus
de fluidité
lorsque vous allez venir scrollé vous
aurez donc un truc beaucoup plus
confortable au niveau visuel vous
donnera aussi une meilleure expérience
lors de partygaming
donc pourquoi pas 80 dire c'est cool
mais 90 ans s'était déjà présent dans
les smartphones l'année dernière shewan
plus cette année samsung a présenté une
gamme le galaxy s 20 avec des écrans 120
hertz ou enplus sera en passe de
présenter un smartphone avec un écran
200 hertz ont déjà beaucoup misé sur
leurs écrans 120 hertz donc le sens
d'ailleurs ça devient un peu la norme
sur les smartphones haut de gamme cette
année en 2020 on se demande donc
pourquoi est ce que je suis au mit
arrive avec un smartphone avec un écran
90 heures ce qui est en dessous de ce
que font un peu les challengers d'autant
plus que sur le reste de la fiche
technique ils ont eu ce qu'ils sont
vraiment extrêmement intéressant ça
c'est une question vraiment si
intéressante parce que il faut
effectivement faire des coupes normale
en chimie vous savez il est challenger
on peut pas tout avoir il faut faire des
choix pour réussi un petit peut réduire
les coûts effectivement ils ont des
marges sont extrêmement faibles
mais il leur faut malgré tout faire des
choix d'un point de vue technique car
ils peuvent pas tout avoir
avec des smartphones extrêmement
intéressant en termes de prix pourquoi
est ce que cette fois ci ils sont
contentés de mettre uniquement ce qui
est bien très bien et uniquement parce
que je regarde par rapport à ce qui se
fait ailleurs pourquoi uniquement un
écran 90 ans et non pas à l'écran 200 m
that is the key l'expérience multimédia
devrait être calme pas mal avec ce grand
écran 2
7 pouces et des haut-parleurs stéréo
donc plutôt cool pour l'aspect gaming
l'aspect multimédia visionnage de série
youtube compagnie netflix et j'en passe
d'autres
mais là où ça devient intéressant c'est
lorsque vous regardez du côté du
processeur lorsque j'étais à hawaï pour
le lancement des nouveaux processeurs
snapdragon de qualcomm
qualcomm a annoncé que le midi de chien
aux mines sur le premier smartphone
équipé du soc de qualcomm du nouveau soc
de qualcomm du snapdragon 865 ça semble
être le tout premier
bien que samsung ait présenté son galaxy
s 20 avec une version us équipe existe
un dragon 865 deux jours avant aux us
c'est pas très grave il reste quand même
en tout cas dans les premiers à le faire
on se retrouve sur les deux modèles de 8
à 12 il ya drame lp ddr5 de 128 à 512
giga de stockage en uf6 3.0 lui fs3 de
retrouver déjà l'année dernière chez one
plus on sait très bien que je suis aux
mille intégré là dessus du wifi si ce
qui permettra de profiter d'une
meilleure connexion notamment en fibre
ça ira beaucoup plus vite
bien évidemment de la 5g passe oui
effectivement la 5g arrive en france en
2020 et pas qu'en france
et bien évidemment du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé les annonce
également une technologie qui s'appelle
multi link qui va faire une espèce de
bascule intelligent pour profiter d'une
meilleure connexion à n'importe quel
moment que ce soit entre de la 4g de la
5g et du wifi si votre wifi [ __ ] dans
la semoule paf vous switchez sur la 5g
si vous l'avez si vous ne l'avez pas sur
le lac est chez vous on a toujours ce
qui va le plus vite pour vous connecter
à internet
donc c'est en tout cas c'est bien ça va
vraiment dans le bon sens et au plus une
technologie de refroidissement qui
permettra effectivement nous refroidir
vos smartphones lors des séances de
gaming lorsqu'il hérite potentiellement
un peu de chauffer pour en tirer le
meilleur parti et avoir la meilleure
expérience globale leur smartphone
extrêmement puissant extrêmement
performant qui est adapté complètement
pour la connectivité donc une fois de
plus on se dit pourquoi un écran 90e
alors soir était logique d'aller
complètement au top de ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui avec un écran de sens
inverse allez savoir sur le midi on a
une batterie de 4780 millan paire eur
tandis que son ami dix pros ne passerait
de 4500 milliards eur bon ça se joue à
pas grand chose et fait un petit écart
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
la puissance de recharge sur le me
disent vous rechargez avec un chargeur
filaire de 30 watts ce qui est
globalement pas trop mal tandis que sont
les milices pro en à charger filaire de
50 watts 30 watts sans fil et la
recherche inversée 10 watts pour venir
charger à nos smartphones pour nuire
chargé des écouteurs wireless enfin tout
ce que vous voulez et nous annonce une
recherche de 0 à 100% en 45 minutes
autant dire ça bombarde tout s'attendre
à bien évidemment sur me wade 11 basé
sur landreau 10 10
maintenant ce qui vient peut départager
les deux appareils c'est la partie photo
on voit que le 1010 propres aux
professionnels est vraiment adapté pour
permettre plus de flexibilité en termes
de photos tandis qu'avec le me disent
vous aurez un bon capteur voir quelque
chose qui est en tout cas très alléchant
est très intéressant mais on n'ira pas
aussi loin dans les deux cas vous avez
un capteur de 100 8 mégapixels c'est un
grand temps qui ouvre à f 1.68 qui a
technology 4 pixels en un qui permettra
de sortir des photos en basse luminosité
les photos de 27 mégapixels l'idée si
vous voulez c'est que vous aller capter
beaucoup plus de lumière ça paraîtra
effectivement sortir des meilleures
photos et notamment en mode nuit sur le
modèle pro vont trouver un équivalent 50
mm on appelle ça un tel objectif ça vous
fait un zoom x 2 mais surtout pour le
mode portrait ça va vraiment venir jouer
sur la profondeur de champ et vous avez
un super téléobjectif 8 mégapixels qui
permettrait d'avoir un zoom hybride x 10
avec une ouverture de f 2.0 un ultra
grand angle de 20 mégapixels qui ouvre à
f 2.2 avec un grand champ de vision de
117,2 grec bon du grand standard ça
marche plutôt cool bien lorsque vous
avez beaucoup de lumière qu'on avait pas
beaucoup de lumière se fera ce type
stock la marche un petit peu moins bien
et vous pouvez filmer comme ce qu'on
retrouve aujourd'hui c'est samsung sont
les hells 20 sur toute la gamme ds 20
fois filmée en 8k et sortir directement
des photos en trente trois mégapixels
tandis que sur le midi soit
effectivement les capteurs sur le méga
pixels mais vous avez un 13 mégapixels
en ultra grand temps et vous avez deux
caméra de 2 mégapixels une pour le mode
portrait pour les fai de bloquer et une
pour de la macro mois la macro je suis
réellement pas convaincu le surtout
seront 2 mégapixels c'est un peu rigolo
ça servira globalement a pas grand chose
ces deux caméras là elles ont les
ouvertures de f 2.4 tu nous racontes lui
disent pro terme de photos par être plus
intéressant en plus d'être avec lui me
disent on va pouvoir avoir une caméra un
peu polyvalentes 114 101 8 mégapixels
l'ultra grand temps que c'est bien nous
aurait pas de zoom vous pouvez pas faire
grand chose ne vous dirai pas vraiment
très très très loin donc la meilleure
proposition est la plus intéressante
reste quand même le modèle professionnel
après si vous allez sur le midi vous
irez sur un smartphone ou vous dire
effectivement c'est un truc qui marche
pour qu'il fonctionne bien si la
puissance et la performance et la
connectivité sera plus que je veux j'ai
un très bel écran ginoux son stéréo ça
marche ok c'est cool mais par contre en
terme de photos c'est un peu frustrant
il faut vraiment penser à switcher sur
l'autre nous d'ailleurs là maintenant
c'est là où ça devient très
on parle de tarifs parce que
effectivement c'est là où on peut se
poser la question est ce que c'est la
fin du low cost chez chuo oui est ce que
je suis au mythe encore une marque low
cost vous fait les configs sur le me
disent vous avez trois config 8 gigas de
ram plus 100 étudiants de stockage
vous êtes à peu près vous savez les
conversions vers ajouté la tva vous
seriez environ aux alentours de 630
euros déjà un peu plus aux huit plus de
150 6 680 euros à peu près 12 plus de
150 6 743 rouvriront natcom l'état qui
sont beaucoup plus élevés par rapport à
ce qu'on avait sur le medef à l'ania et
là on va regarder directement avec le
met dix pros et celle là où on peut
vraiment dire se poser la question
8 plus de 156 780 euros on essaie shlomi
n'oublions pas 12 plus de 156 870 euros
12 512 948 euros on passe très
clairement largement au dessus des
tarifs qui sont classiquement proposé
par schumi a quasiment 950 euros sur un
smartphone de chimie en n'ayant pas
d'écran de 100 verte
on est en concurrence avec le dernier
samsung galaxy s 20 on peut se demander
ce que ça vaut le coup d'y aller oui ou
non d'ailleurs a vous de me le dire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaires je me suis posé la question
pendant team ans jeudi est ce que c'est
la fin du retrait on peut agrandir que
ce sommet est une marque low cost alors
en fait ce qu'on voit et ce qui est
vraiment intéressant ce qui est vraiment
symptomatique
c'est que chez lui comme beaucoup de
marques ont compris et depuis très très
longtemps que l'idée pour eux pour
arriver et péter un peu la concurrence
et faire leur place c'est casser les
prix dire ok vous venez chez nous parce
que nous on propose des tarifs
extrêmement cassé avec les meilleurs
techno avec les dernières technologies
et vous serez pas déçus c'est leur angle
d'attaqué et ils ont réussi
ils ont fait leur trou et sont arrivés
depuis quasiment deux ans en europe donc
la strappe elle marche elle est prouvée
elle fonctionne merveilleusement bien
maintenant il a compris que pour
préserver peut-être des marges et pour
se positionner face à d'autres produits
et bien il fallait monter en gamme et
c'est effectivement ce qui nous propose
avec ce me disent mais surtout avec le
milices pro alors montée en gamme plutôt
bien qui me semble assez être réussie
dressent encore un petit peu sur ma faim
avec cet écran de 90 ans je reste un peu
tatillon là dessus mais pourquoi pas à
côté de ça le wifi si je trouve ça très
très bien c'est un des rares sont
attendus aujourd'hui à proposer le du
wifi si cela 5 g c'est bien mais c'est
obligatoire en 2020 lui ai fait trois
points en février d'après technologique
d'un polype m'en fiche technique qui
font taf là dessus pour moi il n'y a
aucun souci donc monte en gamme il faut
pas des tarifs plus élevés pour venir
dragué une
si les plus exigeantes qui veut des
produits avec le top d'autres on peut se
faire aujourd'hui en termes de
technologie il n'abandonne pas pour
autant le milieu de gamme arabe sont
présents avec une gamme qui est
extrêmement large et bien évidemment ils
sont toujours présentes dans l'entrée de
gamme avec plein de smartphones
notamment les smartphones de répit donc
à pas mal de jeunes en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est pas que schumi n'est plus une
gamme low cost
elle vient à s'étendre et à s'étirer en
fait voici tirer vers le haut elle garde
cette base elle garde ses fondamentaux
mais elle vient vraiment draguer une
nouvelle cible toujours plus exigeante
voilà un petit peu ce que tous genres
forêt ce que j'en pense bien évidemment
ces smartphones on va aller les voir on
va les découvrir on va les tester en
long en large et en travers on en
parlera tout aller parce que sur mr des
produits tout le temps bien une gamme
qui est extrêmement complète qui des
fois devient un petit peu complexe mais
sur le principe au tout cas la
compression de valeur est toujours
intéressante à vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire moi
j'ai hâte de les tester à d'ailleurs je
suis très déçu une pipe à 2 mwc cette
année néanmoins il faut garder le
principe de précaution pour la santé
dont c'est quand même relativement
normale en reparlera de firmi
extrêmement rapidement vous invite donc
à vous abonner si pas déjà le cas
et bien évidemment de garde tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire sur
ce je vous embrasse
on s'en veut de l'amour à demain
[Musique]